desde 1910 a 1945 la actual Corea del
Sur estuvo bajo El dominio colonial de
Japón con más de 780.000 surcoreanos
movilizados como trabajadores forzosos
para empresas japonesas o esclavos
sexuales para el ejército una parte
dolorosa de su historia que ha
entorpecido las relaciones entre seúl y
Tokio en un nuevo intento por Reparar
los lazos Corea del Sur propuso un plan
para compensar a las víctimas japonesas
de trabajos forzados y a sus familias
como parte del apoyo a las víctimas de
trabajos forzados y a sus familiares la
fundación para las víctimas de la
movilización forzada por el Japón
Imperial pagará indemnizaciones e
intereses de demora a los demandantes de
tres sentencias del tribunal supremo en
Además de que el dinero de las
indemnizaciones sea financiado por
empresas surcoreanas del sector privado
seúl Espera que las empresas japonesas
tomen también la iniciativa de
contribuir Japón acogió con satisfacción
la decisión pero subrayó que sus
empresas no están obligadas a pagar
puesto que el tratado de Tokio de 1965
ya había establecido un paquete de
reparaciones de 800 millones de dólares
en subsidios y préstamos baratos pero en
2018 el tribunal supremo de Corea del
Sur obligó a las empresas japonesas a
pagar más indemnizaciones directamente a
las víctimas en la mañana del lunes el
plan de seúl ha recibido reacciones
negativas de las familias de las
víctimas que acusan al gobierno de
capitular ante Tokio
es lamentable el gobierno de Johnson
sigue adelante con negociaciones
comerciales Pro japonesas que pisotean
los derechos legales establecidos de sus
ciudadanos y eximen la responsabilidad
legal a las empresas criminales de
guerra japonesas
es una violencia inaceptable
Washington ha saludado la medida como un
nuevo capítulo innovador e insta Japón y
a Corea del Sur a presentar un frente
unido para contrarrestar las amenazas
nucleares de Corea del Norte